Let's consider a very famous
problem the, Atwood machine.
We have a pulley, A,
suspended from a ceiling.
And a rope is wrapped
around the pulley.
And on each side of the rope,
there's different masses.
So here is block 1,
and block 2, and we
can say here-- it
doesn't matter--
but we'll say that
M2 is bigger than M1.
And that gives us
some intuition that we
expect block 2 to go down
and block 1 to go up.
Now in this problem
there is friction
between the rope and the pulley,
so the rope is not sliding.
And what that means is that
the pulley will rotate.
And also the mass of
the pulley is not 0.
So these were all assumptions
we made way back when
were analyzing
Newton's second law,
but now we have to
take into effect
that there some
rotational inertia to make
the pulley start to have
angular acceleration.
So what we'd like to do is to
identify our three objects--
mass 1, the pulley, and mass 2.
And for mass 1 and mass 2,
use Newton's second law,
for the pulley, we'll use
our torque relationships.
So let's begin by
drawing our free body
diagrams for object 1.
So we have tension in the
rope pulling object 1 up,
we have the
gravitational force down.
And here it doesn't
matter which way
I'm going to choose my
unit vectors, because I
have this idea that
M2 is bigger than M1.
I'm just going to
choose j hat 1 up.
Now for block 2, I have M2g.
Now here's the place where
lots of people get tripped up.
In the past we've been assuming
that the tension in the rope
is uniform everywhere.
In this problem, because
the rope is not slipping
and the pulley is not
massless, the tension
is not constant
everywhere in the rope.
And we'll see more reasons why
that can't be the case, so I'll
have to identify a different
tension on the other side T2
pulling the rope,
pulling the block up.
And I'm going to
choose j hat 2 down.
Notice my unit vectors are
chosen in opposite directions.
The reason for that is that
there's a constraint here
that as block 2 goes
down, block 1 goes up,
if the acceleration of
block 2 is positive,
the acceleration of
block 1 will also
be positive if I choose
unit vector pointing up.
So now I can write Newton's
second law for both of these.
So for block 2, positive down,
and 2g minus T2 equals M2a.
It's the same
acceleration in the rope.
a is equal to a1, equal to
a2, they're all positive.
And for 2, notice
I have positive up
minus M1g equals m1a.
So so far, these are
my two equations.
I have three unknowns-- T1,
T2, and the accelerations,
and only two equations.
Now let's analyze the pulley.
So we have our
pulley A. And what
are the forces on the pulley?
Well forces and torques
are a little bit different,
but let's just draw
our forces first.
There is a tension
holding it up,
we'll call that T3 from
this rope pulling it up.
Now here's where we
have to be careful.
Rope 1 is pulling the pulley
down, that's what we called T1,
so we draw a T1 on this side.
And the same rope
on the other side
is pulling the pulley down.
Notice that it is
a different, T2.
Now this brings us to what
we called our rotational
coordinate system.
I do know expect
that the angular
acceleration of the pulley.
So as the pulley
rotates in this problem,
I expect that it's
rotating in the direction
like by the right
hand rule, this way.
And so I expect to see the
alpha pointing like that.
What I'll do is I'll choose a
coordinate system for an angle
theta.
And that will make
positive direction
like that for my rotational
coordinate system.
Now when we write torque
equals the moment of inertia
of the pulley, times the
angular acceleration,
we have two torques.
The radius is R, radiuses
of R. And if we're
calculating the torque about
the center of the pulley,
we'll call that point 0,
then each of these torques
are in different directions.
So for instance, we
would have to take for T1
going down and this vector from
origin to where T1 is acting,
we can extend that force.
And we see that that torque
is pointing in the direction
in-- direction like that.
And that's opposite
or sign here.
So this torque, minus
T1 R is negative.
What about the torque
from the other force, T2?
Again, we would
draw that vector.
Let's draw them over here.
We have T2 pointing down.
The point 0 is there.
The vector from 0 to 2
is pointing like that.
We extend that vector.
We put the arrow like that.
And we see that
this one is pointing
in our positive direction.
So we have a plus
T2R equals IA alpha.
Now right away we can see why
the tension in the strings
is not the same.
Because if these
tensions were the same,
this quantity would
be 0, but the tensions
can't be the same because
the pulley is rotating.
And that rotational
inertia of the pulley
is coming from the fact
that the two torques are not
the same on both sides.
So we now have our
last equation here.
T2R minus T1R equals IA alpha.
But notice that I've introduced
another variable here,
so I guess again, I have
four equations and only
three unknowns.
We still have one
last constraint.
Because the rope is
sliding along the pulley
and the radius is R,
we know that a point
on the rim of the pulley has
acceleration A of the rope.
But the pulley has an
alpha angular acceleration,
so our constraint conditioned
here is plus R alpha.
Now why did I put a plus sign?
Because when the pulley is
rotating the direction shown,
alpha will be positive.
This quantity, torque, will
be bigger than this one,
and so we'll have
a positive alpha.
When I chose j hat 1
up and j hat 2 down,
that made all my
accelerations positive,
and so I with the plus side.
If I had reversed my
choice of unit vectors,
then this would be a minus sign.
So you have to be extremely
careful by making sure
that the directions you
chose for the linear force
diagrams that give us A,
and the direction we chose
in our rotational
coordinate system
are consistent when
we choose to relate
the constraints between them.
So that's our last condition
that a equals our R alpha.
So I now have four
equations and four unknowns.
And if I want to solve
for the acceleration a,
then I have to need
a strategy here.
And what I'll do to find a
is I'll use this equation
as my backbone.
Why did I do that?
Because I have the
unknowns T2, T1, and alpha.
And I have separate equations
that relate alpha to A,
and T1 to a and T2 to a
And so I can solve for T2.
And substitution here
I'll need a little room.
So I get that T2
is M2g plus M2a.
I'm sorry, minus M2a times R.
Now T1 is M1a plus M1g times R,
and that's equal to times
AI alpha, which is a over R.
So I'll now collect all
of my a terms over here.
And so I get to M2gR minus
M1gR, this term and this term,
is equal to a times
IA over R. Notice
I have 2 plus signs here,
so I get M1 plus M2 times R.
And I therefore conclude,
we'll put it over here,
that the acceleration a of is
equal to M2 minus m1gR, divided
by IA over R, plus M1 plus M2R.
Now, when I have this
result, let's just
check a number of things first.
Notice that if M2
is bigger than M1,
a will be positive,
which is what I expected.
Dimensionally, we have
M2gR, down here, M2R,
so this first term will have
dimensions of acceleration g.
Now over here, we
have IA over R,
but remember moment of
inertia is M times R
square, so this also have the
dimensions of mass and radius.
And so I have confidence
dimensionally.
And the sine of A that
this is the correct answer.
And that's how we solve
the Atwood machine.